This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. At the Olympic Games in 2021, one athlete arrived in Tokyo with a mountain of expectations on her four foot eight inch frame. Five medals in real, four of them gold, and could do even better than that this time around here in Tokyo. If you don't think that that's hard, then you really don't understand gymnastics. People didn't just expect how to win gold medals and gymnastics. The expected magic.
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。2021年奥运会上，一位运动员带着如山般的期望，以四英尺八英寸的身躯抵达东京。她曾获得过五枚奥运奖牌，其中四枚是金牌，而这一次在东京，她本可以做得更好。如果你认为这并不难，那你真的不了解体操。人们对她的期望不仅仅是赢得金牌，而是期待奇迹。
So I mean, she has just set herself so far apart from the rest of the field and not just on the condition for it. 4 days into the games. It happens in the company! And Biles pursuit of history starts tonight. Four days into the games, Simone Biles pulled out of the competition. I've just never felt like this going into a competition before, and I tried to go out here and have fun and warm up in the back when a little bit better, but then once I came out here, I was like, no, mental is not there. The world was stunned. out here I was like no, mental is not there.
我的意思是，她让自己与赛场上的其他人拉开了巨大的差距，而不仅仅是在竞技状态上。奥运会开赛四天后，事情发生了！拜尔斯对历史的追逐今晚开始。奥运会开赛四天后，西蒙·拜尔斯退出了比赛。“我以前参加比赛时从未有过这种感觉，我试着在这里享受乐趣，在后台热身时感觉还不错，但一旦来到这里，我就觉得，不，我的心理状态不在线。”全世界都惊呆了。来到这里，我就觉得，不，我的心理状态不在线。
The world was stunned. An athlete with seemingly other worldly powers was struggling. From the outside looking in, it seemed hard to understand. And it raised a question, if a world champion can be toppled by these emotions, what does it mean for the rest of us? This week on Hidden Brain, the strange psychology of the voice inside our heads that says, the world may think you are amazing, but you are really just a fraud. It's hard to see ourselves clearly. This is true in all manner of situations,
全世界都惊呆了。一位看似拥有超凡能力的运动员陷入了困境。从局外人的角度来看，这似乎很难理解。这引发了一个问题：如果一位世界冠军都能被这些情绪击倒，那对我们其他人来说意味着什么？本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们将探讨内心那个声音的奇怪心理学，它会说：“世界可能认为你很了不起，但你其实只是个骗子。”我们很难清晰地审视自己。这种情况在各种情况下都是如此，
but it can be especially true when we are confronting a challenge. At such moments, many of us start to doubt ourselves. We think we are unequal to the task. At the University of Texas at Austin, Kevin Cochley researchers the psychology of self-doubt. He studies the corrosive effects these doubts can have on our well-being, but also how we might turn our internal misgivings into an ally. Kevin Cochley, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Kevin, you're a psychologist who studies the
但当我们面临挑战时，情况尤其如此。在这样的时刻，我们许多人开始怀疑自己。我们认为自己无法胜任这项任务。在德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校，凯文·科克利研究自我怀疑的心理学。他研究这些怀疑对我们幸福感产生的腐蚀性影响，以及我们如何将内心的疑虑转化为盟友。凯文·科克利，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。谢谢你的邀请。凯文，你是一位研究
phenomenon of self-doubt. Yet you yourself have not been immune to such doubts. I want to take you back to when you were 29 years old. You were just completed your PhD, you had begun teaching. Can you describe the fears that went through your mind as you prepared for class each day? Yes, I was a young assistant professor at Southern Illinois University at Carbondale and I can recall very vividly the feeling that I had walking the hallways at the psychology department there and seeing on the walls these publications by my new colleagues, very accomplished colleagues, and I had come out of graduate school
自我怀疑现象的心理学家。然而，你自己也未能幸免于这种怀疑。我想带你回到你29岁的时候。你刚完成博士学位，开始教书。你能描述一下你每天准备上课时脑海中闪过的恐惧吗？是的，当时我是南伊利诺伊大学卡本代尔分校的一名年轻助理教授，我能非常清晰地回忆起走在心理学系走廊里的感觉，看到墙上贴着我新同事们的出版物，他们都是非常有成就的同事，而我刚从研究生院出来，
having only one publication. I believed that I was hired on the basis that people saw potential in me, particularly in terms of my teaching, but I knew that I had a lot to prove in terms of research. And so when I was walking those hallways, I had this sense of wow, like, can I do this? And it was incredibly stressful. It sort of had me doubting whether,
只有一篇出版物。我相信我被录用是因为人们看到了我的潜力，特别是在教学方面，但我知道在研究方面我还有很多东西需要证明。所以当我走在那些走廊里时，我有一种“哇，我能做到吗？”的感觉，这让人压力巨大。这让我怀疑，
in fact, I belonged, whether I deserve to be there. And I was aware that I was one of only a few black professors at the university. And so I did not want to do anything that would result in students seeing me or believing me to not be qualified to be the professor. So I made sure that I wore sports coats and wore ties to class every day. I had a briefcase that I bought because in my mind, a professor carries a briefcase. And so I was really working hard to project an image of expertise and authority that I imagined professors needing to represent.
事实上，我是否属于这里，我是否配得上这里。而且我意识到我是大学里为数不多的黑人教授之一。所以我不想做任何会导致学生认为我不够格或者不相信我能胜任教授职位的事情。所以我确保每天都穿运动外套和系领带去上课。我买了一个公文包，因为在我看来，教授应该提着公文包。所以我真的很努力地投射出一种我所想象的教授需要展现的专业和权威形象。
I understand that one way yourself doubt manifested was that you were worried about misspeaking in class, saying something wrong. And I'm wondering when you imagine making a mistake like that, what was the worst case scenario that ran through your head? Speaking in front of a large introductory class, psychology class, I thought, man, I cannot stand here and misspepeak I need to make sure that I'm conjugating you know my verbs correctly I need to make sure that I'm enunciating every word exactly correctly and so for me the worst case scenario would have been to be lecturing and to say something incorrectly and
我了解到，你自我怀疑的一种表现是担心在课堂上说错话。我想知道，当你想象犯那样的错误时，你脑海中闪过的最坏情况是什么？在大型心理学入门课上发言时，我想：“天哪，我不能站在这里说错话，我需要确保我的动词变位正确，我需要确保我发出的每一个词都绝对准确。”所以对我来说，最坏的情况就是在讲课时说错了什么，
then to have my students questioning my authority and ability to be an effective professor. And so for me, that was a worst case scenario. You've been a professor for a while now. You clearly know what you're doing. You have a lengthy publication record. Have yourself doubts gone away? You know, that's a good question.
然后让学生质疑我的权威和作为一名有效教授的能力。所以对我来说，那是种最坏的情况。你当教授已经有一段时间了。你显然知道自己在做什么。你有很长的出版记录。你的自我怀疑消失了吗？你知道，这是一个好问题。
It depends on the day that you ask me the question. When I'm speaking to people and when people are introducing me and they're reading my accolades, on the one hand I feel pretty good about what I've been able to accomplish. But there are still some days when I find myself doubting what I have the expertise to be able to speak in front of people. And when I talk to my students about this, they find it amazing because they have Dr. Kevin Cochley on somewhat of an academic pedestal.
这取决于你问我这个问题是在哪一天。当我向人们演讲，当人们介绍我并宣读我的荣誉时，一方面，我对自己的成就感到相当满意。但仍有一些日子，我发现自己怀疑是否有足够的专业知识在人们面前发言。当我与学生谈论这一点时，他们觉得很惊讶，因为他们把凯文·科克利博士放在了某种学术神坛上。
And when I tell them that even Dr. Cochley sometimes still suffers and still wonders about my deservedness to be in the position that I'm in, they are surprised. So I do still have those experiences. So Kevin, it looks like you yourself are a walking example of this phenomenon that you have studied for many years. In popular culture, it's called the imposter syndrome. Now, you think that term is overly clinical.
当我告诉他们，即使是科克利博士有时也会感到痛苦，仍然会怀疑自己是否配得上现在的职位时，他们感到很惊讶。所以我确实仍然会有那些经历。那么凯文，看来你本人就是你研究多年的这种现象的活生生的例子。在流行文化中，这被称为“冒充者综合症”。现在，你认为这个术语过于临床化了。
You prefer the term imposter phenomenon. Can you describe for me what the imposter phenomenon is? and post-phenominant. Can you describe for me what the impostor phenomenon is? The impostor phenomenon is basically the sentiment that one is being intellectually fraudulent. It's the idea that individuals who are very accomplished, very competent, very intelligent people, nevertheless feel like they are fooling people.
你更喜欢“冒充者现象”这个术语。你能为我描述一下什么是冒充者现象吗？冒充者现象基本上是一种认为自己在智力上是欺诈者的感觉。这种想法是，那些非常有成就、非常有能力、非常聪明的人，却仍然觉得自己在欺骗别人。
They believe that they are not nearly as smart and competent as their accomplishments would suggest. So, we're going to talk about the factors that produce these kinds of self-doubt and what we can do about these misgivings, but I want to start by looking at the different dimensions of self-doubt because when you start to peel this onion, it turns out to be a really complex phenomenon. I want to play your clip of the actress Viola Davis talking to the CBS program 60 minutes. I don't know if it's healthy or not. I'm just saying that it's something that I recognize and all the artists I've worked with.
他们认为自己并不像他们的成就所暗示的那样聪明和能干。所以，我们将讨论产生这种自我怀疑的因素，以及我们能对这些疑虑做些什么，但我首先想看看自我怀疑的不同维度，因为当你开始剥开这层洋葱时，它竟然是一个非常复杂的现象。我想播放一段女演员维奥拉·戴维斯接受哥伦比亚广播公司《60分钟》节目采访的片段。我不知道这是否健康。我只是说，这是我在所有合作过的艺术家身上都能认出的一种东西。
It's in all of them. So I know the language of the artist and the language of the artist is, someone's going to find me out. I may not be as great as people think I am. I may not be as great as people think I am. So one dimension of self-doubt here is that you worry that others might have an inflated sense of how good you are, that you might not be able to live up to those expectations. Yeah, that is one of the hallmarkmark traits of imposter feelings.
它存在于他们所有人身上。所以我了解艺术家的语言，艺术家的语言就是：“有人会发现我的真面目。我可能并不像人们认为的那样伟大。我可能并不像人们认为的那样伟大。”所以这里自我怀疑的一个维度是，你担心别人可能对你的评价过高，你可能无法达到那些期望。是的，这是冒充者心理的标志性特征之一。
When you have friends and colleagues telling you how great you are and saying all of these nice and wonderful things about you, you find yourself just wondering, can I live up to these lofty expectations and you can't help but sort of feel that I can't live up to that. So when Viola Davis made those remarks,
当你的朋友和同事告诉你你有多棒，并对你说所有这些美好而美妙的话时，你会发现自己只是在想：“我能达到这些崇高的期望吗？”你禁不住会觉得：“我无法达到那种程度。”所以当维奥拉·戴维斯发表这些言论时，
it really sort of represented some of the classic hallmark signs of imposterism. So I'm wondering if this might be especially acute for an actor, but I think all of us might experience some version of this. When you're shooting a movie, they don't show the audience all the takes when someone flubbed the line or made a mistake.
它确实代表了一些冒充者心理的经典标志。所以我想知道这对于演员来说是否特别强烈，但我认为我们所有人可能都会经历某种形式的这种感觉。当你拍摄电影时，他们不会向观众展示所有那些有人念错台词或犯错的镜头。
So, Viola Davis thinks that we, the audience, associate her with the perfection of the roles she's playing on the screen, what we see on the screen, she, on the other hand, knows the whole picture, the, you know, all the mistakes, the off days, and she worries that our picture of her and her picture of her might not match. You are absolutely correct. What we see is the sort of perfected version of who she is as an actress.
所以，维奥拉·戴维斯认为我们观众将她与她在银幕上扮演角色的完美联系在一起，也就是我们在银幕上看到的东西；而她自己则了解全貌，你知道，所有的错误、状态不佳的日子，她担心我们对她的印象和她对自己的印象可能不匹配。你是完全正确的。我们看到的是她作为一名女演员的完美版本。
What we don't see are, as you said, the many outtakes that I'm sure she's had to go through in order to get finally the perfect scene. Again, it's the idea that one you know, one needs to try to be perfect because you believe that people sometimes see you as being perfect when you know that to not be true about yourself. Hmm. So, why were the Davis was asked to play the role of Michelle Obama in a showtime series titled The First Lady? And she described Michelle Obama as a goddess. I want to look at the next dimension of self-doubt and play you a clip.
我们没有看到的是，正如你所说，我相信她为了最终获得完美的场景而不得不经历的许多废弃镜头。同样，这是一种需要努力追求完美的概念，因为你认为人们有时视你为完美，而你知道这对自己来说并非事实。嗯。那么，维奥拉·戴维斯被邀请在Showtime系列剧《第一夫人》中扮演米歇尔·奥巴马的角色。她将米歇尔·奥巴马描述为一位女神。我想看看自我怀疑的下一个维度，并为你播放一段片段。
Here is Michelle Obama talking about a question that goes through her own mind all the time. Am I good enough? That's a question that has dogged me for a good part of my life. Am I good enough to have all of this? Am I good enough to be the first lady of the United States? And I think that many women and definitely many young girls of all backgrounds walk around with that question. I still feel that at some level, I have something to prove
这是米歇尔·奥巴马在谈论一个一直萦绕在她自己脑海中的问题。“我够好吗？”这是一个在我生命中大部分时间里一直困扰我的问题。“我有资格拥有这一切吗？我有资格成为美国第一夫人吗？”我认为许多女性，当然还有许多各种背景的年轻女孩，都在带着这个问题生活。我仍然觉得在某种程度上，我还有东西需要证明，
because of the color of my skin, because of the shape of my body, because of who knows how people are judging me. So I feel like Michelle Obama is speaking to another dimension of self-doubt. And perhaps this is similar to your own experience with self-doubt as a 29-year-old assistant professor. And this one of self-doubt is not that other people think too highly of you, but the fear that other people might think that you're a fraud. Yeah, and I found myself smiling because that is the exact clip that I use in every imposter phenomenon
因为我的肤色，因为我的身材，因为谁知道人们是如何评判我的。所以我感觉米歇尔·奥巴马正在谈论自我怀疑的另一个维度。这也许和你自己29岁时作为助理教授的自我怀疑经历相似。这种自我怀疑不是别人对你评价太高，而是担心别人可能会认为你是个骗子。是的，我发现自己笑了，因为那正是我在每一次冒充者现象演讲中使用的片段。
talk that I give. I was actually saying the words along with her as she was saying it. But yeah, no, you're right. In this instance, she's talking about the feelings of self-doubt that she has about herself, but that are really rooted in, I would argue, societal views about people who look like her, people whom she would represent. Now, you might think that one form of self-defense against these feelings is to just simply prove you're very good, but it turns out that doesn't always work.
当她说这些话时，我实际上也在跟着说。但是的，不，你是对的。在这种情况下，她谈论的是她对自己产生的自我怀疑感，但我认为，这些感觉实际上植根于社会对像她这样的人、她所代表的人群的看法。现在，你可能认为抵御这些感觉的一种自我防御方式就是简单地证明你非常优秀，但事实证明这并不总是有效。
The poet Maya Angelo won three Grammys for her spoken word albums. She won the Pulitzer Prize for poetry and the presidential medal of freedom. If she had never written another word in her life, her reputation would have been secure. But you've talked about how she was also plagued by self-doubt. Yeah, she talks about, you know, having published 11 books and still finding herself wondering, uh oh, they're gonna find me out. And you know, and when I talk about her,
诗人玛雅·安杰洛凭借她的口语专辑获得了三项格莱美奖。她获得了普利策诗歌奖和总统自由勋章。如果她一生中从未写过其他任何文字，她的声誉也会稳固。但你谈到她也曾深受自我怀疑的困扰。是的，她谈到，你知道，出版了11本书，却仍然发现自己在想：“噢，不，他们会发现我的真面目。”你知道，当我谈论她时，
I say, look, she is Maya Freakin' Angela. You know, she's one of the greatest portuses that we've ever, you know, experienced. And yet, even Maya Angelou has had these feelings of being, you know, found out that she is somehow fraudulent and fooling people. And so she is a beautiful example of someone who has achieved at the very highest level, nevertheless still feelings that they are fraudulent.
我说：“看，她是玛雅·安杰洛。”你知道，她是我们要经历过的最伟大的诗人之一。然而，即使是玛雅·安杰洛也有这种被“发现”是某种欺诈者、在愚弄别人的感觉。所以她是那些在最高水平上取得成就，却仍然感到自己是欺诈者的绝佳例子。
You know, I'm struck by the similarities between self-doubt and conspiracy theories. Go along with me for just a second here. On the surface, these are very different ideas, but one thing that unites them is that if you're played by self-doubt or you subscribe to a conspiracy theory, the evidence does not disabuse you of your belief. So in the case of a conspiracy theory, you find ways to discount the evidence that contradicts the theory.
你知道，自我怀疑和阴谋论之间的相似之处让我感到震惊。请跟我一起思考一秒钟。表面上看，这些是非常不同的想法，但将它们联系在一起的一点是，如果你被自我怀疑所困扰，或者你认同某种阴谋论，证据并不能消除你的信念。所以在阴谋论的情况下，你会找到方法来否定与该理论相矛盾的证据。
And in the case of self-doubt, as with Maya Angelou, no amount of past evidence that you're talented seems to convince you that your fears are not warranted. No, I mean, that's absolutely right. In fact, it almost kind of reminds me of that social psychological concept or confirmation bias. You are more oriented toward finding evidence that supports the contrary, that would support, you know, the idea of you not being competent, even though, again, your accomplishments
而在自我怀疑的情况下，就像玛雅·安杰洛一样，无论过去有多少证据表明你很有才华，似乎都无法让你相信你的恐惧是没有根据的。不，我的意思是，那绝对是对的。事实上，它几乎让我想起了那个社会心理学概念——确认偏误。你更倾向于寻找支持相反观点的证据，即支持你没有能力的观点，尽管同样，你的成就
would suggest otherwise. So I can actually see the connection. Yeah, there's one last dimension of self-doubt that I wanna place on the table. The actor Tom Hanks has long been one of Hollywood's biggest stars, but like Viola Davis, he has said that he also worries that he is soon going to be found out. No matter who we are, he has said that he also worries that he is soon
会表明事实并非如此。所以我确实能看到其中的联系。是的，我想提出的最后一个自我怀疑的维度。演员汤姆·汉克斯长期以来一直是好莱坞最大的明星之一，但像维奥拉·戴维斯一样，他说他也担心自己很快就会被发现。无论我们是谁，他说他也担心自己很快
going to be found out. No matter who we are, no matter what we've done, there comes a point where you think, how did I get here and am I going to be able to continue this? When are they going to discover that I am in fact a fraud and take everything away from me? It's a high wire act that we all walk and I do this in the work that I do because there are days when I know that three o'clock tomorrow afternoon, I am going to have to deliver some degree of emotional goods and if I can't do it, that means I'm going to have to fake it. And if I fake it, that means they may catch me at faking it.
就会被发现。无论我们是谁，无论我们做了什么，总有一个时刻你会想：“我是怎么走到这一步的？我还能继续下去吗？”他们什么时候会发现我其实是个骗子，并夺走我的一切？这是我们所有人都在走的钢丝，我在我的工作中也这样做，因为有些日子我知道明天下午三点，我将不得不提供某种程度的情感价值，如果我做不到，那就意味着我必须伪装。如果我伪装，那就意味着他们可能会抓住我在伪装。
And if they catch me at faking it, well, then it's just doomsday. What strikes me in this clip, Kevin, is another dimension of self-doubt, and we've discussed this elsewhere in Hidden Brain. Many of us subject ourselves to the kind of scrutiny and criticism we would never dream of aiming at other people. Can you talk a moment about the harshness of our inner critic? Are you yourself hotter on you than you are on other people?
如果他们抓住我在伪装，好吧，那简直就是世界末日。凯文，在这个片段中让我印象深刻的是自我怀疑的另一个维度，我们在《Hidden Brain》的其他地方也讨论过这个问题。我们许多人对自己施加了那种我们绝不会对别人施加的审视和批评。你能谈谈我们内心批评者的严苛吗？你自己对自己是否比对别人更严厉？
Yeah, I think that's a really good question. And I know that certainly I can see elements of that in myself, you know, when I've done something that is noteworthy and for which I should be proud of. And nevertheless, I can still find reasons to be critical of it, to find reasons to not be as as happy or by the or excited by the or two sort of embrace it as a worthy accomplishment. And so being our own harshest critics, that's something that I see, that I can hear in what Tom Hanks said, and certainly I can see elements of that in myself. Yeah. There's a theme that runs through many of the examples of imposter phenomenon that we have discussed. You know, Maya Angelo, sort of written Levin books, thinks that she's a fraud. The writer John Steinbeck is supposed
是的，我认为这是一个非常好的问题。我知道我当然可以在自己身上看到这些因素，你知道，当我做了一些值得注意且应该感到自豪的事情时。然而，我仍然可以找到批评它的理由，找到理由不去那么快乐、兴奋，或者不去拥抱它作为一项值得的成就。所以成为我们自己最严厉的批评者，这是我在汤姆·汉克斯所说的话中看到的东西，当然我也能在自己身上看到这些因素。是的。在我们讨论过的许多冒充者现象的例子中，有一个主题贯穿始终。你知道，玛雅·安杰洛写了11本书，却认为自己是个骗子。作家约翰·斯坦贝克据说
to have once written something very similar. He wrote, I'm not a writer. I've been fooling myself and other people. And even the physicist Albert Einstein is supposed to have once called himself an involuntary swindler. Now on the surface, all of this seems incomprehensible. You know, you've written amazing books. If you've reinvented the world of physics, how can you think of yourself as a cheat and a swindler? Why do you think it is that people who are plagued by self-doubt cannot see the brilliance that is playing for us to see
曾经写过非常相似的东西。他写道：“我不是作家。我一直在愚弄自己和别人。”甚至物理学家阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦据说也曾称自己为“非自愿的骗子”。表面上看，这一切似乎不可理解。你知道，你写了很棒的书。如果你重塑了物理学世界，你怎么能认为自己是个骗子和欺诈者呢？你认为为什么那些被自我怀疑困扰的人看不到我们从局外人角度所能看到的才华呢？
when we look in from the outside? You know, I mean, I think that's the million dollar question. I mean, that's something that we are still in many ways trying to figure out. But what I will say is that if you've come from environments where you were sort of complimented on things unrelated to your intelligence, let's say that you were someone who was very socially skilled, let's say you were someone who was very sort of athletic. And all you ever heard from people, family, and friends
你知道，我的意思是，我认为那是价值百万美元的问题。我的意思是，这是我们仍在以多种方式试图弄清楚的事情。但我会说，如果你来自那种对与你的智力无关的事情进行赞美环境，比如说你是一个社交能力很强的人，比如说你是一个非常有运动天赋的人。而你从家人和朋友那里听到的所有话
was about your prowess in those areas, but you never received feedback about your intelligence. Then part of that can result in you internalizing this idea that maybe you're not that smart. Maybe your talent us lie elsewhere, that's part of the origins of these feelings. The most successful people among us doubt their abilities from time to time.
都是关于你在这些领域的实力，但你从未收到过关于你智力的反馈。那么其中一部分可能会导致你内化这种想法，即也许你并不那么聪明。也许你的才华在别处，这就是这些感觉的起源之一。我们当中最成功的人也会不时怀疑自己的能力。
Self-doubt can be so powerful that it makes us feel like frauds in our own lives. When we come back, the origins are self-doubt and what we can do about that negative voice in our heads. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Lots of smart, talented, accomplished people, harbor self-doubt. They worry they are frauds and imposter, even when they have ample evidence, there is no need for such fear. At the University of Texas at Austin, psychologist Kevin Cochley studies the psychology of self-doubt and the imposter phenomenon. Kevin, the psychologist Pauline Clans and Suzanne Eimes, first used the term imposter phenomenon in a 1978 study. They focused on high-achieving women.
自我怀疑的力量如此强大，以至于让我们在自己的生活中感到像个骗子。当我们回来时，我们将探讨自我怀疑的起源，以及我们能对脑海中那个消极的声音做些什么。你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。许多聪明、有才华、有成就的人都怀有自我怀疑。他们担心自己是骗子和冒充者，即使他们有充分的证据表明这种恐惧是不必要的。在德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校，心理学家凯文·科克利研究自我怀疑和冒充者现象的心理学。凯文，心理学家保琳·克兰斯和苏珊·艾姆斯在1978年的一项研究中首次使用了“冒充者现象”这个术语。他们关注的是高成就女性。
Can you describe that study for me and what they found? These were women who came from very diverse backgrounds. Some of them came from the world of corporate America. Some of them were academic. Some of them were graduate students. But what they all had in common was they were all incredibly accomplished women. And it was interesting because when they worked with them, they kept repeatedly hearing
你能为我描述一下那项研究以及他们的发现吗？这些女性来自非常不同的背景。她们中的一些人来自美国企业界。一些人是学术界的。一些人是研究生。但她们的共同点是，她们都是非常有成就的女性。有趣的是，当他们与她们合作时，他们不断地反复听到
these feelings of self-doubt in spite of the accomplishments that they had as individual women. And so they led them to theorize that this idea of the impossible now, but now was something salient among women because again, this was the population they were working with. Now, now the examples of, you know, people like Tom Hanks or Albert Einstein and you yourself, Kevin, might suggest the impostor phenomenon doesn't just affect women. Is that data to back up the anecdotes? That's absolutely true. I mean, in my own work, I have public studies where in one study, in positive feelings were certainly more prevalent among women than men, but in another study
这些自我怀疑的感觉，尽管她们作为个体女性取得了成就。因此，这引导他们推测，这种冒充者现象的概念在女性中是显著的，因为这正是他们当时研究的人群。现在，像汤姆·汉克斯或阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦这样的人，以及你自己，凯文，的例子可能表明冒充者现象不仅仅影响女性。有数据支持这些轶事吗？这是绝对正确的。我的意思是，在我自己的工作中，我发表过研究，在一项研究中，冒充者心理在女性中确实比男性更普遍，但在另一项研究中
that I published, there was no difference between men and women. And what we know from the accumulation of work that's been done in this area is that there has not been any consistent findings of women experiencing higher and positive feelings than men. Now, that being said, and I talk about this a lot, I do believe that with women that the implications of imposter feelings are a bit different than among men. And I point to one of the studies that I published where I was looking at factors that predict GPA. And what I found in that study was that even though there were no differences between men and women in terms of their imposter feelings,
我发表的研究中，男性和女性之间没有差异。我们从该领域积累的工作中了解到，没有任何一致的发现表明女性比男性经历更高的冒充者心理。话虽如此，我经常谈论这一点，我确实相信对于女性来说，冒充者心理的影响与男性略有不同。我指出我发表的一项研究，我当时正在研究预测GPA的因素。我在那项研究中发现，尽管男性和女性在冒充者心理方面没有差异，
imposter feelings had no link to GPA for men. It did not impact their grades at all, but for women, imposter feelings were, in fact you linked in very sort of clear ways to their GPA. So you can say on the one hand that there were no differences in the reporting of in positive feelings amongst both groups, but the implications of those in positive feelings were quite different for men and women. What about racial differences here, Kevin? We've talked about several prominent black people who experienced self-doubt, but you've conducted studies looking at racial differences in, Kevin? We've talked about several prominent black people who experience self-doubt, but you've conducted studies looking at racial differences in self-doubt,
冒充者心理与男性的GPA没有任何联系。它根本没有影响他们的成绩，但对于女性来说，冒充者心理确实以非常明确的方式与她们的GPA相关联。所以你可以一方面说，两组人在报告冒充者心理方面没有差异，但这些冒充者心理对男性和女性的影响却大不相同。凯文，这里的种族差异呢？我们谈到了几位经历过自我怀疑的杰出黑人，但你进行过研究，观察种族差异，凯文？我们谈到了几位经历过自我怀疑的杰出黑人，但你进行过研究，观察种族差异，
and some of the results are both revealing and surprising. What do you find? So, in the initial study that I published, we had a very diverse sample of college students consisting of Asian Americans, African Americans, and Latinx Americans. And we went into the study thinking that we would see evidence of higher and positive feelings among African Americans and Latinx Americans.
其中一些结果既有启发性又令人惊讶。你发现了什么？所以，在我发表的初步研究中，我们有一个非常多样化的大学生样本，包括亚裔美国人、非裔美国人和拉丁裔美国人。我们带着认为会在非裔美国人和拉丁裔美国人中看到更高冒充者心理证据的想法进入了这项研究。
And we believe that because of what we understand to be some of the ideas and beliefs surrounding African-American students and Latinx students around intelligence and around their deservedness to be in some predominant white educational spaces. But what we found, in fact, was quite the opposite. We found that Asian American students in our particular sample reported higher feelings
我们之所以这样认为，是因为我们理解围绕非裔美国学生和拉丁裔学生在智力方面以及在某些以白人为主的教育空间中应得地位的一些想法和信念。但事实上，我们发现的情况恰恰相反。我们发现我们特定样本中的亚裔美国学生报告了更高的
of imposterism than both African-American students and Latinx students. And this was counterintuitive to what we expected to find. And we tried to explain it somewhat speculatively on the idea that Asian-American students are, you know, have to sort of deal with that modern minority myth in ways that sort of exacerbate those feelings. I mean, it might be a little bit like what we discussed earlier about Viola Davis basically saying, you know, other people think that I'm perfect, but I know I'm not perfect,
冒充者心理，超过了非裔美国学生和拉丁裔学生。这与我们预期的发现背道而驰。我们试图推测性地解释这一点，基于亚裔美国学生必须以某种方式应对“模范少数族裔”神话，这加剧了这些感觉。我的意思是，这可能有点像我们之前讨论的维奥拉·戴维斯基本上说：“你知道，别人认为我很完美，但我知道我不完美，”
and that creates a kind of dissonance in my mind. Yes, absolutely. You hinted at something a moment ago, and I'm wondering if we can explore this a little bit more, which is there seems to be a connection between highly competitive environments and the internal generation of self-doubt. You talk, for example, about walking down the corridors at your first job and seeing the publications of other professors in the wall, and in some ways, having this be a reminder for you that you had not done as much.
这在我的脑海中产生了一种认知失调。是的，绝对是。你刚才暗示了一些事情，我想知道我们是否可以进一步探讨这一点，那就是高度竞争的环境与自我怀疑的内在产生之间似乎存在联系。例如，你谈到在第一份工作中走在走廊里，看到墙上其他教授的出版物，在某种程度上，这提醒你，你还没有做那么多。
Can you talk about the link between being in a competitive environment and the experience of self-doubt? When you are in environments that are stressful and that are particularly competitive, these always become incubators for these imposter feelings. Again, if I use myself as an example, the story that you shared about me being a 29-year-old professor, straight out of graduate school,
你能谈谈处于竞争环境与自我怀疑体验之间的联系吗？当你处于压力大且竞争特别激烈的环境中时，这些环境总是会成为这些冒充者心理的孵化器。同样，如果我以自己为例，你分享的关于我作为一名29岁教授、刚从研究生院毕业的故事，
it was a competitive environment. Part of it, I think, may have been just my own internalization because it wasn't like I had my colleagues come into me and constantly reminding me, you know you're a competitive environment, you know you have to do this. No, it wasn't anything so explicit. Yeah. But it was, it was, it was just the subtle reminders that you are now a professor in a very productive competitive environment, and they didn't have to say anything to me. I was reminded by those publications that I saw on the walls.
那是一个竞争激烈的环境。我认为其中一部分可能只是我自己的内化，因为并不是我的同事走过来不断提醒我：“你知道这是一个竞争激烈的环境，你知道你必须这样做。”不，没有那么明确。是的。但它只是微妙的提醒，提醒你现在是一个非常高效、竞争激烈的环境中的教授，他们不需要对我说任何话。我被墙上看到的那些出版物提醒了。
You know, you've talked about another idea about, you know, how we communicate with young people, especially in educational settings. If you communicate to a young person, you know, I think you're a genius, I think you're a prodigy, I think you're special. In some ways, we might think that we are communicating encouragement to the person, but we're also putting expectations on that person. So when that person doesn't do well in a study or doesn't do well in a test, I mean, you know, they're now comparing their performance with what they believe you think of their performance and they feel like they're falling short.
你知道，你谈到了另一个关于我们如何与年轻人沟通的想法，特别是在教育环境中。如果你对一个年轻人说：“我认为你是天才，我认为你是神童，我认为你是特别的。”在某种程度上，我们可能认为我们在向那个人传达鼓励，但我们也在给那个人施加期望。所以当那个人在学习中表现不好或在考试中表现不好时，我的意思是，他们现在正在将他们的表现与他们认为你对他们表现的看法进行比较，他们觉得他们没有达到要求。
Is there a risk in some ways in overinflating, you know, the student's sense of how good they might be or how good they ought to be? I think there is a risk. I mean, and certainly there is nothing wrong with offering encouragement. I think all students need encouragement. But to your point, I do think that one could go overboard with the praise and set students up for
在某种程度上，过度夸大一个学生对自己有多好或应该有多好的感觉是否存在风险？我认为存在风险。我的意思是，当然，提供鼓励并没有错。我认为所有学生都需要鼓励。但就你的观点而言，我确实认为一个人可能会在赞美上做得过火，并让学生为
Struggling with these sort of fittings or self-doubt if the level of praise Exceeds what they either believe about themselves or maybe even exceeds what they have actually accomplished I mean, I think that the deliverance of praise should be appropriate to the the level of accomplishment and not do so You know in an exaggerated manner. So, sometime ago we had the psychologist Claude Steele on Hidden Brain. It was in an episode titled How They See Us. And he talked about the phenomenon of stereotype threat. When you believe you're the target of stereotypes, those fears can be a source of worry and that worry can undermine your performance. There seems to be some overlap between your work on the imposter phenomenon and Claude's
挣扎于这些自我怀疑的感觉做好准备，如果赞美的程度超过了他们对自己信念的程度，或者甚至超过了他们实际取得的成就。我的意思是，我认为赞美的传递应该与成就的水平相适应，而不是以夸张的方式进行。所以，前段时间我们在《Hidden Brain》上邀请了心理学家克劳德·斯蒂尔。那是在一集名为《他们如何看待我们》的节目中。他谈到了“刻板印象威胁”现象。当你相信自己是刻板印象的目标时，这些恐惧可能成为担忧的来源，而这种担忧会损害你的表现。你的冒充者现象研究与克劳德的
work on stereotype threat. I was having this conversation two days ago and I was asked this very same question, so it's something that I thought about for a while. The way that I describe it is there. When you think about Claude's deals working, you know, it's this idea that individuals are aware of stereotypes that exist about once, you know, a particular social identity group, whether that's based on race or gender or whatever. And you don't necessarily believe the stereotypes that exist about the group, but you are aware of them and it's the awareness of that stereotype that ends up disrupting
刻板印象威胁研究之间似乎有一些重叠。我两天前还在进行这个对话，有人问了我同样的问题，所以我思考了一段时间。我描述它的方式是这样的。当你想到克劳德·斯蒂尔的工作时，你知道，这是一种认为个体意识到关于某个特定社会身份群体（无论是基于种族、性别还是其他）存在的刻板印象的想法。你不一定相信关于该群体的刻板印象，但你意识到它们，正是对那种刻板印象的意识最终破坏了
your performance. That's different from in positive feelings because within positive feelings we're talking about individuals who have internalized these beliefs that sort of lead to self-doubt. You found that self-doubt can be a predictor of stress, especially for minorities in educational settings. Can you talk about that work? Yeah, so one of the most common types of studies that you see done with the Impossifin Abhinai is looking at two outcomes related to mental health.
你的表现。这与冒充者心理不同，因为在冒充者心理中，我们谈论的是那些已经内化了导致自我怀疑的信念的个体。你发现自我怀疑可以成为压力的预测指标，特别是对于教育环境中的少数群体。你能谈谈那项工作吗？是的，所以你在冒充者现象研究中看到的最常见的类型是观察与心理健康相关的两个结果。
You know, I tend to look at symptoms of depression and anxiety as my outcomes. And what we have consistently found is that individuals who experience imposter feelings have elevated symptoms of depression and have elevated symptoms of anxiety. They are certainly linked consistently. Is it accurate to say that women and minorities in the workplace or educational settings might be especially prone to this correlation? I believe that to be the case, absolutely.
你知道，我倾向于将抑郁和焦虑的症状作为我的结果。我们始终发现的是，经历冒充者心理的个体抑郁症状升高，焦虑症状也升高。它们确实始终相关。说女性和少数群体在工作场所或教育环境中可能特别容易产生这种相关性准确吗？我相信确实如此，绝对是。
And I approach my work with the belief that for women and for bipock individuals, that this sort of association between mental health and impulsive feelings is especially prevalent. Self-doubt can keep us from seeing ourselves clearly. It can prompt us to downplay our accomplishments and underestimate our skills. It can cost us in terms of mental health and in terms of our willingness to take on new challenges. But there is a deep paradox here. Even as lots of people suffer from needless self-doubt, many also suffer from an absence of self-doubt. Many people who ought to doubt themselves seem filled with blight self-confidence. When we come back, how to combat the imposter phenomenon,
我带着这样的信念进行我的工作：对于女性和有色人种个体来说，这种心理健康与冒充者心理之间的联系尤其普遍。自我怀疑会阻止我们清晰地审视自己。它会促使我们淡化自己的成就并低估自己的技能。它会让我们在心理健康和承担新挑战的意愿方面付出代价。但这里有一个深刻的悖论。即使许多人遭受不必要的自我怀疑，许多人也遭受缺乏自我怀疑的困扰。许多本该怀疑自己的人似乎充满了盲目的自信。当我们回来时，如何对抗冒充者现象，
but also how to make room in our lives for the gift of self-doubt? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Even the best of us can sometimes feel we don't know what we're doing. We worry that we will fall short of other people's expectations. We worry that we will be called out as frauds and shallotants. At the University of Texas at Austin, psychologists Kevin Cochley studies the imposter phenomenon and what we can do about it. Kevin, one technique you've suggested that people use to reduce self-doubt is to
以及如何为自我怀疑的礼物在我们的生活中留出空间？你正在收听《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。即使是我们中最优秀的人，有时也会觉得不知道自己在做什么。我们担心自己会达不到别人的期望。我们担心自己会被指为骗子和江湖骗子。在德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校，心理学家凯文·科克利研究冒充者现象以及我们能对此做些什么。凯文，你建议人们用来减少自我怀疑的一种技巧是
remind themselves of their accomplishments. You say that you sometimes stock yourself. What do you mean by this? Yeah, so one of the things that happens with people who experience imposter feelings is that we don't acknowledge accomplishments to the extent that they should be acknowledged. And so we sometimes just minimize them. And you know, I somewhat half jokingly said that I stalk myself, but you know what I mean is that and I hope people out there listening don't judge me too harshly. I go on Google almost every day and I Google myself. I look up, you know, my metrics surrounding my publications, you know, how many times I've been cited, you know, how many publications I have. I mean, those numbers don't
提醒自己取得的成就。你说你有时会“跟踪”自己。你是什么意思？是的，所以经历冒充者心理的人会发生的一件事是，我们没有在应该承认的程度上承认成就。所以我们有时只是把它们最小化。而且你知道，我半开玩笑地说我“跟踪”自己，但你知道我的意思，我希望听众不要对我评判太严厉。我几乎每天都上谷歌，搜索我自己。我查找，你知道，围绕我出版物的指标，你知道，我被引用了多少次，你知道，我有多少出版物。我的意思是，那些数字不会
change day to day, but I find myself looking at them every single day because I need to remind myself But I find myself looking at them every single day because I need to remind myself That that people think that you're kind of a big deal for a reason that you actually have done something of Note as a as a scholar. Yeah, and so that's my way of just sort of reminding myself that You are deserving of the attention and the accolades that you have received and And if I didn't do that, then it would be easy to sort of forget that I have accomplished this as an academic. Yeah, I mean, I suppose it's the way you can Google yourself every day in order to stroke your vanity.
每天都在变化，但我发现自己每天都在看它们，因为我需要提醒自己，人们认为你是个大人物是有原因的，你实际上作为一名学者做了一些值得注意的事情。是的，所以这是我提醒自己的一种方式，即你配得上你所获得的关注和赞誉，如果我不这样做，那么很容易忘记我作为一名学者已经取得了这些成就。是的，我的意思是，我想这是你可以每天谷歌自己以满足虚荣心的方式。
But I think what I'm hearing you say is actually something quite different. It's almost like a sort of a cognitive behavioral therapy intervention because your mind is not automatically remembering all the things that you've done well or your mind is coming up with self-doubt by actually going and looking at the evidence every day, you're in some ways telling your mind, look, the belief that I have that I'm not worthy or that I'm not up to this task, this belief is on true. So in some ways, it feels almost like a form of therapy
但我认为我听到你说的其实是完全不同的东西。这几乎就像一种认知行为疗法干预，因为你的大脑不会自动记住你做得好的所有事情，或者你的大脑会产生自我怀疑，通过每天去查看证据，你在某种程度上是在告诉你的大脑：“看，我认为自己不配或无法胜任这项任务的信念，这个信念是不真实的。”所以从某种程度上说，这感觉几乎就像一种
that you've come up with on your own. Well, it is. And I'm so glad that you mentioned the word vanity, because I fear that what I just said come across as just someone obsessed, you know, with himself and seeing, you know, what he's accomplished. And it's really not that, although I can understand how it might sound that way because in my case,
你自己想出来的治疗方法。嗯，确实是。我很高兴你提到了“虚荣”这个词，因为我担心我刚才说的话会被理解为一个只沉迷于自己、只看到自己成就的人。事实并非如此，尽管我可以理解为什么它听起来像那样，因为在我的情况下，
yeah, I really truly sometimes find it hard to accept the fact that I am somewhat of an authority on the impossible nominat. And so when I go and look up sort of what I've done, like I sometimes actually forget how much work I've done in the area And I hope that people don't sort of take that to be someone who's just unduly vain about his work and rebeying that way because I'd like to think that it is not that. Yeah, I'm not hearing that at all, Kevin. You said a second ago that you find it hard
是的，我真的有时觉得很难接受我作为冒充者现象权威的事实。所以当我去看我所做的事情时，我有时实际上忘记了我在该领域做了多少工作。我希望人们不要认为我是一个对他人的工作过度虚荣的人，因为我想认为事实并非如此。是的，凯文，我一点也没听出那种意思。你刚才说你发现很难
to accept sometimes that you're an authority on the imposter phenomenon. You do see the irony here, right Kevin, which is you're an expert on the imposter phenomenon who finds it difficult to accept that you're an expert on the imposter phenomenon. I do see the irony in that statement, yes. There's another idea that in some ways is a related idea, which is, you know, there are people whose accomplishments are not public, you know, they don't have publication records, they don't have awards, but in some ways these people can mind the same idea that you're talking about with something
有时要接受你是冒充者现象方面的权威。凯文，你明白这其中的讽刺意味吧，你是冒充者现象的专家，却发现很难接受自己是冒充者现象的专家。是的，我确实明白这句话里的讽刺意味。还有另一个想法，在某些方面是相关的，那就是，你知道，有些人并没有公开的成就，他们没有发表记录，没有获得奖项，但在某些方面，这些人可以挖掘你所谈论的同一个想法，用一种
called a work diary. Can you explain that idea to me? Yeah, so, you know, one of the other suggestions that I give to people is to keep a work diary where you essentially document those successes that you've had in the work environment. What ends up happening for people who experience and positive feelings is that it becomes very easy for us to just sort of either forget or to minimize or marginalize those things that we've done well during the course of a day, during the course of a week. And so sometimes we have to be intentional about documenting those little successes that in the aggregate, you know, are pretty impressive.
叫做工作日记的东西。你能给我解释一下这个想法吗？好的，你知道，我给人们的另一个建议是写工作日记，你基本上记录下你在工作环境中取得的那些成功。对于那些经历过积极感受的人来说，最终发生的情况是，我们很容易忘记、淡化或边缘化我们在一天或一周中做得好的事情。所以有时我们必须有意识地记录下那些微小的成功，这些成功加在一起，你知道，是相当令人印象深刻的。
So Kevin, we've talked about ways that individuals can manage their self-doubt. Are there things that organizations can do that can also reduce self-doubt? Yes, there certainly are things that organizations can do. The example that I like to give involves individuals who are managers or supervisors. What you can do as a manager or a supervisor to really sort of mitigate these sort of feelings of imposterism amongst your subordinates is being transparent in your own vulnerabilities and to be open and sharing this with their employees. It really helps individuals who are afraid to own or to sort of say, I've made a mistake. it makes them feel like, you know what, if my manager
凯文，我们已经讨论了个人管理自我怀疑的方法。组织是否也能做些什么来减少自我怀疑呢？是的，组织当然可以做一些事情。我喜欢举的例子涉及经理或主管。作为经理或主管，为了真正减轻下属的这种冒充者心理，你可以做的是在自己的脆弱性方面保持透明，并乐于与员工分享。这真的能帮助那些害怕承认或说出“我犯了一个错误”的人，这让他们觉得，你知道吗，如果我的经理
or if my supervisor can talk openly about making a mistake, then it's okay for me to make a mistake, and I don't have to be perfect. And I think that goes a long way towards helping to assuage any feelings of imposterism that an individual might be experiencing. Researchers have also looked at ways to dismantle the imposter phenomenon in schools. At Stanford University, Greg Walton looked at the problems that incoming freshmen were facing. And he found that when the experienced setbacks, many of them drew global conclusions like, you know, I don't belong here or I don't deserve to be here.
或者我的主管能公开谈论犯错，那么我犯错也没关系，我不必追求完美。我认为这对于缓解个人可能经历的任何冒充者心理大有帮助。研究人员也研究了在学校消除冒充者现象的方法。在斯坦福大学，格雷格·沃尔顿研究了新生面临的问题。他发现，当他们经历挫折时，许多人会得出全局性的结论，比如，你知道，我不属于这里，或者我不配待在这里。
And he felt like blacks were especially likely to feel like they were frauds. And so he set up an intervention that helped black students see setbacks in the proper perspective. So a bad test result or a bad interaction with a professor didn't mean that they were frauds, it didn't mean they were imposter, it just meant that they were having a bad day or a bad week. Here's a clip of Greg describing the effects of his intervention.
他觉得黑人学生尤其容易觉得自己是骗子。因此，他建立了一个干预措施，帮助黑人学生以正确的视角看待挫折。所以，糟糕的考试成绩或与教授的不愉快互动并不意味着他们是骗子，并不意味着他们是冒充者，这只是意味着他们度过了糟糕的一天或一周。这是一段格雷格描述他干预措施效果的片段。
What the intervention did was it prevented students from feeling that they didn't belong in general when they had negative experiences. You can then imagine how if you're feeling less vulnerable to threats, you are better able to connect with other people, to peers, to teachers, and build the kinds of relationships
这种干预措施的作用是，防止学生在经历负面体验时产生普遍的“我不属于这里”的感觉。你可以想象，如果你觉得受到的威胁较小，你就能够更好地与他人、同龄人、老师建立联系，并建立起那种
that actually sustain performance over a long period of time. Kevin, I'm wondering if you can weigh in on this, is one solution to self-doubt in some ways not blowing things out of proportion, blowing setbacks out of proportion? I love that and thank you for sharing that study. As a council psychologist, I would refer to that as almost like I'm simply reframing it and not sort of internalizing it as being indicative of a trait about yourself. People aren't perfect. And we have to sort of get beyond this idea
能够长期维持表现的关系。凯文，我想知道你对此有何看法，解决自我怀疑的一种方法在某种程度上是不是不要小题大做，不要把挫折看得太严重？我喜欢这个观点，谢谢你分享那项研究。作为一名咨询心理学家，我会称之为重构，而不是将其内化为关于你自身特质的某种标志。人无完人。我们必须超越这种想法
that making mistakes is somehow indicative of you being not smart, not competent, not belonging. The most accomplished people in the world have all experienced failure at some point. And so we need to sort of help students in particular understand that when you failed a test, and I could have benefited from this,
即犯错在某种程度上意味着你不聪明、没有能力、不属于这里。世界上最有成就的人在某个时刻都经历过失败。所以我们需要帮助学生，特别是学生，理解当你考试不及格时——我本可以从中学到东西——
when I was a student, it would have been so helpful if I would have had a professor who would have pulled me to the side and to help me sort of manage the feelings that I was having around my initial sort of early poor performance. It's okay. Just don't let it be defining of who you are and what your potential reality is. And I think we don't have enough of that taking place in schools. You know, Kevin, we started this conversation talking about some of your own insecurities and self-doubt. When you are plagued by self-doubt, even today, you see that you have a go-to solution
当我还是个学生的时候，如果有一位教授能把我拉到一边，帮助我处理我早期表现不佳时产生的感受，那该多有帮助啊。没关系。只是不要让它定义你是谁以及你潜在的现实是什么。我认为我们在学校里做得还不够。你知道，凯文，我们开始这次谈话时谈到了你自身的一些不安全感和自我怀疑。当你今天仍然受到自我怀疑的困扰时，你有一个首选的解决方案
and it involves effort. Can you explain what you do maybe with a specific example? Yeah, well, and I'll start off by, you know, going back to Michelle Obama. Michelle Obama says that what she does is essentially, you know, she works hard. She works harder. So whenever I doubted myself, I just told myself, let me put my head down and do the work. And I would let my work speak for itself.
它涉及努力。你能用一个具体的例子解释一下你做什么吗？好的，我会从回到米歇尔·奥巴马开始。米歇尔·奥巴马说她所做的基本上是，你知道，她努力工作。她更加努力地工作。所以每当我怀疑自己时，我就告诉自己，让我埋头苦干。我会让我的工作说明一切。
And I still find that I do that. And I really identify with that because that has been the way that I try to address my feelings of imposterism. When I think about those early days of my being an assistant professor, I would work late in the evenings. I found myself working on the weekends because I needed to prove to people and I think probably most importantly to myself that I belong.
我发现我仍然这样做。我真的很认同这一点，因为这就是我尝试解决冒充者心理的方式。当我想到我刚做助理教授的那段日子，我会在深夜工作。我发现自己在周末也在工作，因为我需要向别人证明，我想最重要的是向我自己证明，我属于这里。
And so I just, I worked incessantly. Now, I will say that hard work without having a way to sort of balance that with play is not necessarily a good thing, but what I will say is that hard work oftentimes can result in achieving an accomplishment in ways that you would hope would help mitigate whatever feelings of apostorism you might be experiencing. Do you still do that even today, Kevin? Is this your response when someone asks you to give a talk or you have to make a big presentation
所以我只是不停地工作。现在，我要说的是，没有一种方式来平衡工作和娱乐的努力工作并不一定是一件好事，但我会说，努力工作往往能以你希望的方式取得成就，从而帮助减轻你可能正在经历的任何冒充者心理。凯文，你今天还这样做吗？当有人让你做演讲或者你必须做一个重要的报告时，这是你的回应吗
and you're plagued with self-doubt? Do you respond to that by doubling down on the amount of time you're spending in preparation? You know, there are elements of that. When Pauline Clanson, Suzanne, and I think it was really Pauline Clanson, she talked about the imposter cycle. And she talked about these two pathways that people take. You know, the pathway of over-paradness
而你正受到自我怀疑的困扰？你是否通过加倍投入准备时间来回应？你知道，这其中有这些因素。当保琳·克兰森、苏珊，我想真的是保琳·克兰森，她谈到了冒充者循环。她谈到了人们采取的这两条路径。你知道，过度准备的路径
and the pathway of procrastination. And I'm the person who goes through the pathway of over-paradness. And for me, what that means is, when I am giving a talk on the imposter phenomenon, a talk that I have given more times than I can count, I still prepare as though I have never given the talk before. And it's because I want to make sure that when I give the talk
和拖延的路径。而我就是那个走过度准备路径的人。对我来说，这意味着，当我在做关于冒充者现象的演讲时，一个我已经做过无数次的演讲，我仍然像从未做过这个演讲一样准备。这是因为我想确保当我做演讲时
that people hear me and experience me as being an expert and leave no doubt in their mind that I know what I'm talking about. So yeah, there's still elements of that in me even today. I'm struck by what you just said, Kevin, because when I listen to that clip of Viola Davis talk about feeling like an imposter, I didn't play the whole clip for you.
人们能听到我，感受到我是专家，并且对我的专业性毫无疑问。所以是的，即使在今天，我身上仍然有这些因素。凯文，你刚才说的话让我很震惊，因为当我听维奥拉·戴维斯谈论感觉自己像个冒充者的片段时，我没有为你播放完整的片段。
She goes on to say something really interesting, which is, she doesn't say, what was me, I have all these insecurities, feel sorry for me. She talks about how she uses her insecurities as a driver, as motivation. Anybody who even wants to be great has that. Anybody, any filmmaker, any writer, any actor,
她接着说了一些非常有趣的话，那就是，她没有说，我好可怜，我有这么多不安全感，请同情我。她谈到了她如何利用自己的不安全感作为驱动力，作为动力。任何想要变得伟大的人都有这种感觉。任何人，任何电影制作人，任何作家，任何演员，
but what it does on a healthy level, it keeps you humble and it keeps you working. I'm hearing almost exactly what you said to me a second ago, Kevin, which is that in some ways, you know, not believing the good press about you turns out to actually be a powerful motivator for you to actually put your nose to the grindstone, if you will, and not take anything for granted. You know, Violet Davis is so insightful. I mean, she is absolutely correct. And I would say that what she has said definitely applies to me. I think humility is very important. And if I ever got to the point where I lost my humility, I would be brought back to earth by my wife, who was also like a David.
但在健康的层面上，它让你保持谦逊，让你继续努力。我听到的几乎和你刚才对我说的完全一样，凯文，也就是说，在某种程度上，你知道，不相信关于你的好评，实际上证明是你真正脚踏实地、不把任何事情视为理所当然的强大动力。你知道，维奥拉·戴维斯非常有洞察力。我的意思是，她是绝对正确的。我会说她所说的话绝对适用于我。我认为谦逊非常重要。如果我到了失去谦逊的地步，我的妻子会把我带回现实，她也像大卫一样。
She would quickly revive me up. I knew you win. And I think that's necessary because I never want to get to the point where I have forgotten that I was that younger sister professor with one publication and full of self doubts started my career. I never want to forget that person because that person is still inside of me and it continues to fuel me and motivate me to being the best academic that I can be.
她会很快让我清醒过来。我知道你赢了。我认为这是必要的，因为我永远不想忘记我曾经是那个只有一篇论文、充满自我怀疑、开始职业生涯的年轻助理教授。我永远不想忘记那个人，因为那个人仍然在我内心深处，它继续激励着我，促使我成为我能成为的最好的学者。
I'm wondering in some ways, Kevin, whether this might be at least a partial solution to the paradox we identified in the first part of our conversation. You know, we looked at how many brilliant people like Maya Angelou or Albert Einstein have been plagued by self-doubt from the outside that looks bizarre, but is it possible that we actually have mixed up
凯文，我想知道在某种程度上，这是否可能是我们谈话第一部分中确定的悖论的部分解决方案。你知道，我们观察了多少像玛雅·安杰洛或阿尔伯特·爱因斯坦这样才华横溢的人受到自我怀疑的困扰，从外部看这看起来很奇怪，但有没有可能我们实际上搞混了
cause and effect? They are not plagued by self-doubt in spite of being great. Their greatness is being driven, at least in part, by the fuel of self-doubt. No, I think you're right. I think that that is very much a possibility that their self-doubt in part fuels their greatness. I think there's an argument to be made for that. I'm wondering if it might be helpful almost for a moment to think about what would happen if we lived in a world without self-doubt. I'm thinking back to the US invasion of Iraq in 2003, you know, the Bush administration said the invasion was necessary because Iraq was
因果关系？他们并不是尽管伟大却受到自我怀疑的困扰。他们的伟大在某种程度上是由自我怀疑的燃料驱动的。不，我想你是对的。我认为这很有可能，他们的自我怀疑在一定程度上助长了他们的伟大。我认为这有其道理。我想知道，如果我们要思考如果我们生活在一个没有自我怀疑的世界里会发生什么，这是否有帮助。我回想起2003年美国入侵伊拉克，你知道，布什政府说入侵是必要的，因为伊拉克正在
developing weapons of mass destruction. And in one press conference, Defense Secretary Donald Rumsfeld was told that the Iraqi government had denied possessing weapons of mass destruction. Let me play a clip of that press conference. What do you make of the statement made by the Iraqi government yesterday that Iraq has no weapons of mass destruction and is not developing it? They're lying. No, they have them, and they continue to develop them, Iraq has no weapons of mass destruction and is not developing.
开发大规模杀伤性武器。在一次新闻发布会上，国防部长唐纳德·拉姆斯菲尔德被告知伊拉克政府否认拥有大规模杀伤性武器。让我播放那次新闻发布会的片段。你如何看待伊拉克政府昨天发表的声明，即伊拉克没有大规模杀伤性武器，也没有在开发？他们在撒谎。不，他们有，而且他们继续开发，伊拉克没有大规模杀伤性武器，也没有在开发。
They're lying. No, they have them and they continue to develop them and they weaponize chemical weapons. We know that they've had an active program to develop nuclear weapons. It's also clear that they are actively developing biological weapons. So as we know, Kevin, Iraq did not possess those weapons. And I'm wondering if you can talk a moment about what seems like this paradox. How is it that some of us are plagued with self-doubt while others could use a little more self-doubt? You know, that is a very good question and it immediately sort of reminded me of the same pride followed before the man.
他们在撒谎。不，他们有，而且他们继续开发，他们将化学武器武器化。我们知道他们有一个积极的计划来开发核武器。同样清楚的是，他们正在积极开发生物武器。所以正如我们所知，凯文，伊拉克并没有拥有那些武器。我想请你谈谈这个看起来像悖论的问题。为什么我们有些人受到自我怀疑的困扰，而另一些人却可以多一点自我怀疑？你知道，这是一个非常好的问题，它立刻让我想起了“骄兵必败”。
And I think about what happens when hubris gets in the way of our ability to make reasoned and reasonable sort of decisions. And I think that having a bit of self-doubt could save us from really bad situations such as unnecessary wars Among other things and so it it certainly would have been Nice if if Rumsfeld had exhibited a bit more humility than his response indicated But no, I mean I I think I like the way that you sort of connected that to real world implications. And to me, it does sort of go back to this idea of people not feeling so overly confident in themselves in ways that are unhelpful and are unhealthy.
我想到了当傲慢阻碍我们做出理性和合理的决定时会发生什么。我认为有一点自我怀疑可以让我们免于陷入非常糟糕的情况，例如不必要的战争等等，所以如果拉姆斯菲尔德表现出比他的回应所显示的更多的谦逊，那肯定会很好。但不，我的意思是，我认为我喜欢你将它与现实世界的影响联系起来的方式。对我来说，这确实回到了人们不以无益和不健康的方式对自己过度自信的想法。
I can't say enough about how in my own life the need to be humble, to even have feelings of self-doubt have been helpful. Because if I did not have those feelings of self-doubt, then I think that that would one make me probably an unbearable person and not very pleasant to be around. But it also has kept me, I think, hungry
我怎么说都不为过，在我的生活中，保持谦逊，甚至有自我怀疑的感觉是多么有帮助。因为如果我没有那些自我怀疑的感觉，那么我认为这首先会让我成为一个难以忍受的人，不太讨人喜欢。但它也让我保持，我认为，渴望
to continue to work hard to prove myself. And I think, you know, when you get to the point where you stop wanting to prove yourself and when you're no longer hungry and motivated, I don't think that's a very good place to be. So I feel we're in very deep waters here, Kevin. I mean, on the one hand, we've seen how experiencing discrimination, being an outsider, this can increase the risk that you will experience the imposter phenomenon. And that's clearly unfair. Feelings of self-doubt can cause people to drop out of school,
继续努力工作以证明自己。而且我认为，你知道，当你到了不再想证明自己，不再有渴望和动力的时候，我不认为那是一个很好的状态。所以我觉得我们在这里进入了很深的领域，凯文。我的意思是，一方面，我们已经看到经历歧视、成为局外人，这会增加你经历冒充者现象的风险。这显然是不公平的。自我怀疑的感觉会导致人们辍学，
cause them to quit professions that they would be great at. On the other hand, lots of people also turn their insecurity into a superpower like yourself and they use it as fuel. And a lack of self-doubt, especially when you wield great power can produce terrible harm. So I guess I'm left wondering, is self-doubt a bad thing or a good thing? Self-doubt can be a good thing when it is used as a source of motivation to achieve, to excel. But it can come at great cost to one's mental health and to one's physical health.
导致他们放弃本可以做得很好的职业。另一方面，许多人也把他们的不安全感变成了像你一样的超能力，并将其用作燃料。而缺乏自我怀疑，尤其是当你掌握巨大权力时，会产生可怕的伤害。所以我猜我一直在想，自我怀疑是一件坏事还是一件好事？当自我怀疑被用作实现目标、追求卓越的动力来源时，它可以是一件好事。但它可能会以牺牲一个人的心理健康和身体健康为代价。
And so, the challenge then is to figure out how to use oneself doubt in ways that don't result in there being any sort of compromises to your mental health or physical health. And so, the example that I, you know, sometimes share with people, you know, comes from African-American psychology where we talk about the John Henryism hypothesis.
所以，挑战在于找出如何以不导致任何心理健康或身体健康受损的方式使用自我怀疑。所以，我有时与人们分享的例子来自非裔美国人心理学，我们谈论“约翰·亨利主义”假设。
And this comes from a story, folklore, a story of an individual named John Henry who was a steel driver, who was essentially put in a situation where he was competing against a machine to perform it. John Innocent is company. I may name nothing but a man. Before I let your children beat me down, I was diving there now in my hand.
这来自一个故事，民间传说，一个名叫约翰·亨利的个人的故事，他是一名钢钻工，他基本上处于一种与机器竞争以执行任务的情况。约翰·亨利是公司的一员。我可能什么都不是，但我是个人。在我让你的孩子们打倒我之前，我手里拿着钻头。
It's all diving there now in my hand. And the short version of the story is that he wanted to prove that he could outperform this machine. Well, he worked and he worked and he worked. And he eventually did beat the machine. And so his achievement was quite high because he won. But it came at the cost of his life because he ended up dying from the exertion of effort that he gave. So we want to be careful that we don't achieve such incredible feats of accomplishment that
我手里拿着钻头。故事的简短版本是，他想证明他能胜过这台机器。好吧，他工作，工作，再工作。他最终确实打败了机器。所以他的成就相当高，因为他赢了。但这是以他的生命为代价的，因为他最终死于他付出的努力。所以我们想小心，不要取得如此令人难以置信的成就，以至于
also we result in harming our mental health and our physical health. In your own life, Kevin, have you come to think of self-doubt as a friend or as an enemy? Oh, my goodness. That's a, you ask really difficult questions. Self-doubt, I think for me, I would say probably has been more of a friend than an enemy for me. I do try to take care of myself. I work out. I try to be healthy, but I have certainly used self-doubt and ways as a constant source of motivation to make sure that I am not complacent. So I am aware of the things that I need to do to provide this sort of
同时也导致损害我们的心理健康和身体健康。在你的生活中，凯文，你是否开始认为自我怀疑是朋友还是敌人？哦，天哪。这是一个，你问的问题真的很困难。自我怀疑，我想对我来说，我会说它对我来说可能更像是一个朋友而不是敌人。我确实尝试照顾自己。我锻炼。我尝试保持健康，但我确实在某些方面利用了自我怀疑，作为确保我不自满的持续动力来源。所以我意识到我需要做的事情来提供这种
balance, and that I continue to strive to be the best academic that I can be. So I think in my case, it has probably been more of a friend than an enemy. Kevin Cochley is a psychologist at the University of Texas at Austin. He is the author of the myth of black anti-intellectualism, a true psychology of African American students. Kevin, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle,
平衡，并且我继续努力成为我能成为的最好的学者。所以我认为在我的情况下，它可能更像是一个朋友而不是敌人。凯文·科克利是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的心理学家。他是《黑人反智主义的神话：非裔美国学生心理学》的作者。凯文，感谢你今天加入Hidden Brain。谢谢你的邀请。Hidden Brain由Hidden Brain Media制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷尔、
Autumn Barnes, Ryan Katz, and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our unsung hero this week is Hwana Mello. Hwana is a graphic designer who created the Hidden Brain logo in 2015. When we recently launched our new podcast, My UnSung Hero, we knew we wanted to work with Hwana again. She has an amazing eye as you will see when you take a look at the My UnSung Hero logo. More than anything, Hwana cares deeply about what she does and that shows in her work. Thank you so much, one.
奥特姆·巴恩斯、瑞安·卡茨和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是Hidden Brain的执行编辑。我们本周的无名英雄是瓦娜·梅洛。瓦娜是一位平面设计师，她在2015年创作了Hidden Brain的标志。当我们最近推出我们的新播客《我的无名英雄》时，我们知道我们想再次与瓦娜合作。她有着惊人的眼光，当你看看《我的无名英雄》标志时就会明白。最重要的是，瓦娜非常关心她所做的事情，这在她的作品中得到了体现。非常感谢你，瓦娜。
If you like our work, please consider supporting it. You can do so by going to support.hiddenbrain.org. Again, that's support.hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你喜欢我们的工作，请考虑支持它。你可以通过访问support.hiddenbrain.org来做到这一点。再说一遍，是support.hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。